do you have a you have a interesting
relationship with Kanye because I
remember listen I remember well no no no
I remember
um because I wanted to ask you about
this there was one of those rants on the
life of Pablo tour yeah when yay was
like floating above the crowd and in one
of the rants I believe he was in
Sacramento or San Francisco he mentioned
your name specifically in one of these
like 30-minute Kanye rants in the middle
of his performance like obviously since
then you've you know you've seen Kanye
you know he's obviously I'm not talking
about since the uh you know the uh the
current situation he's in yeah but since
that specific instance like what do you
when you wake up in the morning again
you're the most mild-mannered cool dude
and you see Kanye just went on a rant
mentions my name what do you like do you
give a [__] or no it doesn't pay my rent
like I really didn't give a [__] my mom
was excited my family was excited you
know I got hit up around the country
about it but um I mean no I don't even
know what led to that because at that
time we we actually had a really good
relationship and I would go and listen
to his album usually would grab big and
go with him listen to Big Boy and go
listen to his album and so
but but maybe I he wasn't getting the
feedback from me at the time because it
things had started to change from him um
in the marketplace but I don't I don't
even know what what caused the the rant
but um but yeah I thought I thought it
was funny yeah so how long has DJ Khaled
called you doc Winters
doc Winters to the point where I
actually thought about changing my name
to Doc Winters since everybody calls me
it's almost like everyone used to call
Joe Budden Joe Budden it's like it's
winter I think it's funny actually Cal
is my God man great guy yeah he's
hilarious so
another thing I wanted to talk about doc
because I do feel like we are in like a
new era of just the music industry we
talked about streaming we talked about
Tick Tock like what would be your advice
I always tell artists when they ask me
and you can tell me if I'm wrong or not
but I always tell them to worry about
radio last because to me it's like the
last Peg of like you know like if you're
an up and I get hit up by guys with 10
000 followers yeah and they're like yo
man
from [__] I'm from the city put me on
it on real you know I'm just like don't
worry about me yet like yeah no I think
that's good advice yeah I would say
worry the radio is the last thing to
come worry about
you know developing a following your
fans you know getting your [__] off the
ground put an album out something like
but what would be advice you would give
in terms of like just an up-and-coming
artist and how they should maneuver
around getting on the radio
yeah I think it's no different from back
in the day where I think you have to
create a story for yourself like back in
the day we would say create something
locally
no one would probably say create
something socially you know get yourself
a buzz
um I think you got to work on your art I
think because you never know when it's
time to press play and you got to be
ready to do business and I always ask
people like especially after like you
know the first year so so how was it
like yo shit's a Grime like yeah it's
not fun like it's work it's work yeah
it's work you're getting up doing these
morning shows doing these shows and
you're trying to party and then you got
to get up and do shows like it's like
not everybody's built for it you know um
so that's my advice and then also handle
your business yeah um because you may
you may get two albums you may you may
not
um you should have some licensing some
publishing to continue to take care of
your family you may move into a
different aspect of the business but I
think yeah you got to start looking at
it from that perspective because things
can change
what about your advice for a a listen
and I tell anybody who asked me that
they want to get into the radio industry
for the most part
I say I don't know man my time might
have passed like so what if somebody's
watching this and their aspirations are
to do radio it's it's obviously by the
day getting tougher and tougher to crack
because of just the nature of our
business the economics of our business
um what would be your advice to somebody
who wants to get into radio man get
yourself a podcast man
work on your craft
with an opportunity to presents itself
um but but honestly man like there's so
few opportunities for really to hone
your Craft
um I think you got to be on the air
frequently to do that podcast gives you
an opportunity to do that but um I mean
Only the Strong are surviving right now
there's some incredibly talented people
like myself who who are out of work and
then there's some incredibly talented
people like yourself who who have um
carve the niche for themselves and now
they're now they're on more than one
radio station right
there's a lot of people outside of radio
trying to take multiple jobs and I get a
lot of those meetings and you know
sometimes like sometimes I gotta kind of
like throw it back at them like you do
realize what you're asking me to do is
take 25 30 people's jobs and give it to
you right and they've never ever thought
about it that way yeah like you're
expecting yeah like real people's lives
like like honestly because we really
don't have to unless you know we needed
to but you're asking me basically to
take
30 jobs from people and just give it to
you because you know you may or may not
be more talented but it's real you know
and um you know I take that into
consideration it's not something I take
lightly